Oh what's up guys welcome to this past
weekend I am a little under the weather
today we turn these lights down a little
oh yeah I needed a little calmer in here
I might even light a damn candle even
though the people that work here get
upset if we do whatever what's up
welcome to this past weekend I hope you
guys are doing swell what's going on man
you know we didn't do a wreck it's not a
regular start to the episode today it's
a little more low-key I just but I got
home yesterday and I wasn't feeling good
so it just feels sick my head feels like
somebody made like us like like you ever
have like somebody you microwave a
little bowl of Campbell's Campbell's
soup and if my head feels like somebody
microwaved it like a little bowl of
Campbell's maybe that chowder or what
you know with the or like a maybe uh
what else like a beef stroganoff or
something and then and left it in the
microwave never ate it you know they
were high when they cooked it and then
they went to sleep and that's what my
head feels like I just feel like I have
this kind of like bouillabaisse going on
inside of my head and and uh and that's
what I that's okay though whatever I'm
sick that's all right you're here I'm
here and I am happy to be here
today it's Monday morning and you know
everybody you know everybody I was out
of town this weekend but everybody here
in the comedy universe is thinking about
Brody Stephens who passed away and the
news articles were everywhere I'm sure
you saw him all over the internet and
you know Brody uh you know Brody was a
one-of-a-kind performer and people say
that a lot but Brody kind of you know he
loved like knowing where people were
from and being able to relate to people
especially people from California um he
was he was a friendly guy he was a big
but he wasn't but he was he was gentle
he was really gentle fella and um yeah
and it's just you know it's
heartbreaking it's heartbreaking and
I've been thinking about it a little bit
and called a couple people that had
spoken to him last and talked to him
this week and you know he'd been talking
about how he was off his medication he
was struggling or he'd gone off and was
getting back on and that seems to be
what most people are attributing his
uncomfort to you know his
the depth of his uncomfort that it got
to a point where where he took his own
life and where he took his own life by
you know even hanging himself and and I
mean it's just scary I mean it's very
sad you know it's heartbreaking to know
that this human this you know this big
entity I mean he was six for maybe he
was said you know he was loud and he was
he was just he was so alive onstage you
know he used to pitch baseball at
Arizona State he liked to play the drums
he would drum on anything sometimes
during his sets if the sets weren't
going good he would just get drum sticks
or even invisible drum sticks and to
start playing on the chairs in the stage
or whatever you know he he you know just
like any comedian he loved the attention
you know he loved the you know what
there was some equation in the getting
attention from a stage that made him
feel okay you know it made him feel okay
and and it's just wild it's like you you
think like oh well the medicine and I'm
at you know do are you angry at the
medicine but then the medicine may have
been what kept him comfortable for many
years he'd had an instance years ago
where he went off his medication and and
it didn't he had be 5150 I think and I'm
paraphrasing here right you know he went
to a city you know he went into a kind
of a psychosis bit but you know I didn't
know Brody super well I mean I would see
him at the store we would talk nothing
real outlandish you know but he was
always you know nothing real nothing of
a ton of depth unless we were in a
conversation together as it you know
with other people or unless specifically
I was talking to him about baseball or
vitamins he'd love to talk about
vitamins and different things he did to
make himself feel better you know one
thing that I noticed in looking in
thinking about him and looking back at
at watching him perform he always talked
about positive energy he'd say positive
energy
and I always thought I was like man it's
so wild that that's his his Creed it was
kind of the banner that he carried it
was he just he had to he had to tell us
all like you know we have to be forward
you know onward he was a definition of
all inward it was constantly like you
know lifting spirits that was his thing
and and now I'll kind of maybe you know
a realizer I wonder if maybe he was also
just really lifting his own you know he
always talked about the positive energy
because he needed to lift his own
spirits and uh you know you wonder like
you watch someone's act on stage and you
wonder how much of it is real
and how much of it is you know it's like
what's for the audience and what's for
the what's for the the Entertainer
themselves and part of the thing I think
in looking back at Brody and this is
just my perception I could be wrong in
this matter if I'm wrong or right but
that he was you know he was entertaining
the crowd but at the same time he was
lifting himself up like Heaney you know
all the times he talked about relating
to people like he would he would ask
somebody where they played you know
where they went to high school and
they'd say I went to high school it you
know at Reseda middle and then he'd
rattle off the address of the Reseda
middle I know where that is that's it
blah blah blah blah blah Antioch
Boulevard or something and then he would
say relatable like he had related to the
person in the audience
and I guess now I'm just kind of
dissecting you know some of this the way
and so I guess it was like you know he
used these moments on stage to to preach
the things that he needed for himself it
seemed like or to not preach them but to
kind of speak them the best way he could
that he needed he needed to feel related
to and he needed to have positive energy
constantly to keep himself motivated and
excited and that that's how he did it
that he facilitated that they're getting
on the stage a lot and it's just some
you know it's just interesting it's
interesting how many times I sit there
and watch somebody's act and I'm like oh
this is an act but then how many times
am I think I know what in here are the
actual the tools or the the exponents
that this entertainer is using to
actually keep themselves okay today you
know to keep themselves well mentally
well and then I thought Brody huh you
know Brody hung himself and that's just
so you know it's so crazy it's so
foreign it's so alien to think someone
standing on top of something you know
putting a rope around there's just so
many physical moments you have to go
through to do that and now if you're a
short guy it's probably not that you
know it's easy how you could hang
yourself off of a you know off of a
handle on a shipper rope probably if you
had a but a bit of big tall man you know
and then he was a 300 you know Brody was
probably 250
he's thick he had the brownness over
here you know he was brontosaurus he had
them big bones you know I mean you'll
see you might see his bones on the
Flintstones he had those kind of bones
then thick hitters baby them you know he
had that real that dude was marrow
plentiful he had a probably he probably
had about two pounds of marrow in him
straight marrow and you think about
somebody going through those motions and
I'm sorry to talk about some of this but
you know I think I need to think about
it and uh and then I'm not sorry to talk
about it because this is you know this
is what this is but it makes me sad at
me you know the first thing you think is
like could I have done something else
and you know it's uh yeah I hate to say
this but I felt I feel like his death
maybe was unpreventable and I never
thought about this before whenever
someone that I knew had taken their life
or but Brody got a lot of he got it you
know he got a lot of attention at The
Comedy Store on performing he had
friends that he was close to that you
know they talked about mental health he
talked about mental help a lot like
that's another thing if I was switching
doses or something excuse me you know I
take you know I take antidepressants I
take you know um I don't know what -
sertraline or whatever I think it
selects to protect one of those and I'm
switching to something else called
vibrant but but he talked a lot you
could talk to him about that you know
and he would tell you kind of what his
experience had been if he had taken it
something of that or taking something
similar or just you know he would always
you know he seemed like a lifeguard a
little bit on the edge of the pool of
mental wellness
and if you were in the pool you know he
wasn't like that lifeguard that was over
there with the glasses on and the
whistle was trying to [ __ ] everybody you
know whence Keating out with a little
sunscreen here and there you know and
saying they're going to get a soda but
really they're going out to their car to
get a little hit of weed and come back
in there and then they're supposed to
save people when they're high on weed
like people in my hometown used to I
remember going the lifeguard one time
doing a friend of mine I thought he was
drowning her and lifeguard was like man
I'm [ __ ] up brah
and that was it it's how to go and try
to rescue my friend man and thank God I
was able to help you know when an old
man helped who I thought honestly in
hindsight pdf-file man not even because
he kept helping I'm like he helped him
out of the pool then he helped him back
in the locker and whose towel and my
buddy do my buddy would what the [ __ ]
going on out here but but anyway you
know he was like that lifeguard that was
on the pool of mental well on the edge
of the pool of mental wellness and he
could help you he was there to talk to
you if he needed to and he was a caring
guy he had a big heart and I think if
there's anything that I you know we all
think person you know we relate to the
world personally so if there's anything
that I feel remorse for a my own in my
own little life it is that I didn't get
to know the big heart that was inside of
him better you know that I didn't make
more of an effort
and I never knew sometimes if Verde was
being serious or not you know I never
knew I never knew if he was being
serious or not a lot of times but I bet
if I'd I spent maybe a little more time
getting to know him that I would have
known more but I mean that can be said
for anyone in your life goes the way it
goes and you can't know everybody but it
definitely seemed like I haven't heard
anyone say oh there were all these
warning signs there was the fact that he
was changing medication or gone off his
medication with getting back on his
medication and that you know apparently
there was that there's a pretty big dip
sometimes when that happens in your you
know serotonin levels or I don't know
you know I'm going out on you know
everyday jump every day
Jackson rhetoric here but her every day
Jackson diatribe you know I'm just
talking out of my butt but also with
some of my brain in there but then he
went off on those that he went off and
he got back on and there was a dip in
there and then and then that's you know
whenever he found some you know maybe a
level of discomfort hit him and and his
brain wasn't at a level where it could
handle it or something uh you know I
don't know we'll never really know we'll
never really know so you know and it's
crazy to think of its unpreventable I
mean it had been preventable if he
didn't switch his medications maybe but
there wasn't it didn't seem like
anything anybody could have said that
day or did that day you can't spend
every night with someone that you don't
you know you know we can't you know
people can only really do what they're
doing and do the best that they are
doing in a specific instance and you
know and the hanging part is what also
gets me out you know with Robin Williams
hung himself it's such a and I don't
mean this in a base way but I mean this
in a it's such a performer thing you
know it's such a like a display
you know it's like it's like a last it's
like your last bit it's like oh I need
to show you that I'm not doing well
and I couldn't show anyone how bad I'm
feeling or how uncomfortable I feel
except with this last display of art
because it's such a presentation you
know it's such a specific thing it's
like I need to stop my head like I need
to I need to like litigate my head from
my body and that's not called ligature a
ligature yeah I need to stop I need to
stop this head from infecting the rest
of me and this is the only way I know
how to do it is to literally or not
literally but you know I don't know just
to cut it off at the past I need to
tighten right here so that my brain
doesn't keep bothering the rest of me
and I didn't mean to get on it you know
it's just sad man it's very sad and and
people say suicide is selfish and yeah I
think I think suicide is a selfish say
maybe yeah it's you it's your life it's
your relation with the world but I just
don't know how this would have been
preventable you know unless his
medication you know maybe he didn't or
if he wasn't I'm not sure if a doctor
recommended that he switched with his
medication and get off and get back on
or I don't know man
it
sad though it's sad to think that there
was this this being that's just not here
now but I do hope that he's somewhere
where he is at a lot more at peace and
I'm sure that he is what else sorry to
start us off like that I'm not going to
be in here too long today man I do not
feel good I have a fever
I got a fever Saturday and and I just
didn't feel good and I'm sorry that we
didn't do some meet and greets in
Houston for the early shows but there's
not enough time that second show comes
so quick that it would move the second
show back like an hour and you know the
clubs don't really want to roll like
that so but I had a great time and I
loved that Club it was so great so many
you know nice people people came out for
their first comedy shows ever a couple
that I met up in in Wyoming came out to
the show they had been living in Chicago
before and and they said they were just
going to change their lives and move and
head down to Houston they said if you're
ever down there will come and then
they're bang they were there my but you
have a Saturday night I got sick so if I
did do some pictures after Saturday
night after The Late Show and I'm sorry
if I was short with people but at that
point I was just beat man I just didn't
feel good but that Saturday Late Show
van was fire that was such a fun when I
got a standing ovation I never got that
in my life it was kind of interesting
because I didn't really know how to
I mean maybe it sounds bizarre not
trying to be braggy but it just I'm just
trying to take myself through the
moments of it all right
you know somebody stood up and then
somebody else and the next thing you
know like everybody is standing up
clapping and I just felt I don't know I
mean I guess I just felt you know
grateful so thank you guys thank you
Houston my babysitter came out dude they
had a babysitter we had a babysitter
when I was a kid she used to watch us
and I hadn't seen her since then I
hadn't seen her since I was probably
nine and she came out with her husband
and it was you know it's funny she was
just telling me stories of when I was
little and we had you know when she was
you know attractive babysitter to and
when she was still attractive you know
she's been really been holding it down
in the mirror and and it was just great
man we got to just talk about little
things that I remember from being young
and she was able to fill in some of the
blanks and you know told me some stories
about my dad would come home and there
be four kids running around and you know
he's at that point he's probably 77
years old and he would just go straight
to the bar he would just say look I'm
gonna go lick a stamp that's what she
said he told her and that that meant he
was going to get a drink and what else
yes she just talked to you no sir my mom
always worked and that that we were
pretty well behaved children you know we
got into bed on time and she said I wet
the bed which is good to hear cuz I
thought I did and I knew I did so it's
nice to just back that up with a little
bit of evidence but that was a it was a
good experience man had a good
experience down there and turned to go
what else happened man I don't
I got that congestion but I got a couple
of nice gifts somebody gave me this
beautiful little ladybug this young girl
and I was in such a hurry and I felt
that I just didn't feel girl but she
gave me a nice ladybug and um what else
somebody brought me this little care
package had some beautiful socks in it
they had Grover and Sesame Street on him
and nice card and uh a little bit of
picture of a squirrel who else man uh
who else came out what else my doll got
a nice shirt that's really cool TF ATK
style shirt this guy created himself
that was pretty dope yeah there's some
nice gifts you know a young fella came
out that I used to live with when I was
in high school when I was in high school
I went to live with a family and I live
with them for probably three years and
and he came out and I still spend time
with his family every time I go into
Louisiana when I still have a room there
and and and he came out so it was good
to see him you know grateful to him
because you know him just letting me
come and stay over at their house and I
was young it really it gave me more of a
comfortable place where I could just
feel okay you know it gave me that and I
needed that at that time of my life
and I'm grateful for moments like those
because it shows me the value of that
and moving forward in my life if I'm
able to you know provide that for young
people and stuff as I get older if my
you know children have friends one day
and that sort of thing just to see how
there can be value there and just giving
somebody a place where they can find a
little bit of peace you know sometimes
what else I'm going yeah next week I'm
in Boston not this week but next week at
the Chevallier theater Tuesday Thursday
March 7th and then Friday I'm at the
Wilbur Wilbur Saturday mark there
Friday March 8 and then Saturday March
9th I'm at the Borgata then also I'm at
the San Jose improv in late March and
Caroline's in New York City May 3rd and
May 4th
we're gonna decide this week about if
we're gonna be able to add some more
shows in Australia and then start
looking into the fall and I really want
to come over there today UK mate I want
to come to the UK so that would be good
yeah but I was thinking about Brody and
just what it takes to be you know just
what does it take to be okay or to say
I'm not okay that's one thing I noticed
that I never say if you know I'll say
how I'm feeling sometimes but sometimes
I don't want to say really just the
exact words that I'm not okay you know
and I think that's probably what seems
like something that is kind of really
crucial and helpful to people or which
I've noticed to myself was helpful to me
is isn't it fine an environment or a
person where I can say those things you
know just tell somebody like when they
asked me because you always think that
people don't really care that only be
bothered that's another thing if you're
a nice person you don't feel well you
don't want to bother people you know you
don't want to bother them you don't want
to say oh well you know I'm not okay
because you think oh well they're in a
hurry they have to go do this so they
have to do that or they're gonna think
I'm weird or but there's yeah there's
something where we don't we're it's so
hard to say that and for me that's what
I start to find is the thing that I want
to say the most sometimes you know hey
I'm just I'm not okay you know
that's another thing sometimes we feel
like oh I gotta know why I don't feel
good
but that isn't that isn't necessarily
true you don't have to know why you
don't feel good I don't think we don't
know why sometimes I just don't feel
good you know sometimes at us don't
whatever I am whatever the little being
that I am
it doesn't feel okay I don't feel okay
and that's when a lot that's when I find
that I have disconnects in my life is
when there are moments in my life where
I wanted I probably should have told
people that and I didn't say it you know
where it be when I was really young or
whatever I just didn't say it or I
didn't know how to say it or I was
embarrassed to say it I was ashamed
ashamed of myself out huh you know I
don't want to tell him I'm not okay you
know they're gonna think I'm weird or
they're and sometimes a sense of pride
it's like I'm not telling anybody I'm
not okay I'll show them I'm gonna be
okay even though I'm not okay and in the
end you don't really show anybody I mean
you show yourself actually I guess you
show yourself that you are strong but it
seems to be kind of a irreverent
strength that you just kind of create it
because in the end you're not really
empowered so it's not a strength that
really empowers you to say that I'm you
know if you're not okay and and to tell
people that end to end to keep it from
people it's like you you do you do
achieve your goal
well I'm not gonna tell them man I'm
gonna be tough well you achieve that
goal you do so that is you probably get
some sense of achievement from that but
I bet the long-term value of that isn't
that comfortable inside of you because
whatever that route of not okay is it
doesn't really it doesn't really you
know solve it it doesn't really like how
or help figure out where it is or help
follow the route down and the dirt more
but I don't know I just feel for you
know I feel for Brody I feel for anybody
thinking that they're going through that
moment in those moments where your brain
at that point you're you're in another
spatial dimension in your head cuz
you're thinking okay I'm doing this and
this is the only way that I can show
right now that something is wrong
and it makes me wonder about mental
health like what kind of medicine are we
putting on people putting people on
makes me scared about the medicine that
I'm on as I took it this morning I'm
thinking man Oh anyway I didn't mean to
be a downer I did not mean to be a
downer but it's heartbreaking you know
one of the saddest things I feel like or
one thing that I feel like is sad and I
don't know if this is judgmental on
somebody but Brody did a great job of
you know the Comedy Store has like
there's a lot of comics a lot of the
same comics worked there you know it's
just like a lot of comics that are doing
well right now and those change over
time and and you know Brody always had
like kind of a later night spots so he
always was kind of like the king of this
sort of later night group of comedians
in a way that were sort of that are
great comedians but just aren't in the
top like four or five spots and I'm kind
of I'm out there sort of in the middle
of those groups which I'm grateful to be
in and that's their judgement of me and
that's I don't I'm happy to be at The
Comedy Store I am it's the only place in
LA that I really feel comfortable and uh
and Brody was kind of right yeah like
into these sort of late-night spots
where he kind of held down he was kind
of like the king of this little
late-night kind of crew and uh you know
and I just know they're all gonna miss
their you know their fearless leader
that had all this experience
you
you know but rest in peace bud you know
we love you and I'm sorry that we didn't
tell you that more
um what else Bob Kraft got that uh eight
chair that BJ and we don't know and we
may never know all I'm saying is they
definitely deflated his balls you feel
me and they said there's video replay of
it coming soon
which yes I am sixty or seventy days off
form but I will be watching that boy you
don't think I'm gonna watch a six seven
year old Jewish do get us get it get
Jade out in a semi darkroom come on bro
then you don't know me and you don't
know what I'm into I'm joking I'm not
into that but I'll watch it once like
every other straight male I'll watch it
one time um but apparently this was a
hot spot for fellas that wanted to pop
through and get that Jackie a key that
wanted to get that pop pop you know that
Skeeter little little did eat and and
here's what's gonna what's coming to
this arguments like over these people
there were they sex trafficked in this
and that and and that's where it stuff
it's like yeah you want to shut down sex
trafficking also if a woman is using
that method of earning money to survive
and is okay with it you know I think
that there should be protection for
those women as well because some people
are okay with that some people's
sexuality to them is totally is very
different you know and a lot of our
American views are different of
sexuality now for the woman's being
abused or something like that and that's
you know that's really out there that's
on that I mean that's wrong but if this
you know if this lady's just quick with
the carpals and she's just hitting you
with that
and Ginsu and popping them newts out of
you and getting that full body spray
going then what is that I mean that's
nature so but it kind of it's one of the
first things were like Bob Kraft you're
like oh he's just like you know he's
just a regular guy he's driving across
town to get tugged out over there pick
up pick up a little bit of milk and
apples on the way home I don't know what
else good luck to Dustin Poirier that
Louisiana diamond maybe takes a lot of
pressure to make a diamond do it and
they got a they got a good one
Dustin Poirier boy that slithery bad boy
he's gonna get that fight against max
Holloway that title shot in Atlanta on
April 13th and and also Anthony
Lionheart Smith good luck in your battle
with Jon Jones man I mean I cannot even
imagine but uh but you are a braver man
than probably anybody you might be the
bravest man in the world so excited for
both those dudes I've been watching
Dustin's Instagram if you don't follow
this Instagram it's pretty funny
watching him he no go for runs and just
training and you can feel his excitement
and that's exciting man I you know I
like to watch some of these guys because
that's something I'm not brave enough to
do is what they do and it's it's really
exciting to see them get in there like
that um that's it man I'm not feeling
super great so I'm going to call it but
I thank you to everybody that came out
in Houston man there's some people that
I'm forgetting that came out I know it
was just I'm just sorry I didn't get to
spend a little bit more time I meet
everybody the shows were too close
together to do meet in Greece for the
early shows and I did my best for the
late shows to meet everybody and I tried
to sneak out on the early ones and get
into the crowd at the end and uh and
hang out and I'm just sorry that I
didn't get to you know because I know
that's important too to some of you guys
and it's important to me too
it's also you know it's also important
to monitor how I'm feeling so I have
enough energy
to put the show on but I put my all into
those shows and and I just really
appreciate you guys coming out you know
I love to there's a couple moments
sometimes in the show where you know I
just feel like we're in like a little
bit of like huh like a different world
for a second or I don't know what it is
it's just like we're in like a place and
and just everything's kind of okay for a
for a little bit here and there you know
there's some pockets where it just feels
like everything's okay we love you Brody
and um and I'll see you guys next
weekend we got Dane Cook coming in this
week on the podcast so if you got
questions send them in they just had an
interesting article article about him
and variety you know he's trying to make
a comeback
he's a very pro what does it call when
somebody is very polarizing he seems to
be a very polarizing guy so we'll see
let's see what we can talk about you
guys be good to yourselves you probably
deserve it
take care of each other yang gay
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake myself
[Music]